Prof: Well,
I'd like to begin by pointing
out that the first name of
Fredric Jameson is spelled
F-r-e-d-r-i-c.
The reason I point that out is
that most scholars don't seem to
be able to grasp that simple
fact and that references to him,
which are rife in the critical
literature,
perhaps one-third of the time
spell his first name wrong.
So I thought it would be
important for you to be among
the cognoscenti and to know that
it is spelled in the way that I
just mentioned.
It's a strange thing.
When I started teaching I
taught many,
many, many sections of English
129,
and of course in the first
semester,
the first text that we read was
The Iliad.
Now "Iliad"
is spelled I-l-i-a-d.
Why it is that of the student
population I taught over all
those years,
hundreds and hundreds of
students, fully a third of them
spelled it I-l-l-i-a-d I really
couldn't say,
but there are words that simply
seem to be insusceptible to
being spelled correctly,
>
and one of those words is the
first name of Fredric Jameson,
so stand advised.
Okay.
Now last time I talked about
four possible options of an
aesthetic nature for a
Marxist approach to literature,
and passed them in review.
I mentioned realism,
both realism according to the
tastes and theoretical
preferences of Engels and
Lukacs,
and also tendentious realism as
it pervaded the Soviet world,
especially after 1934;
then also the participatory
aesthetic of figures like Walter
Benjamin,
and the high Modernist
aesthetic of the
"whole"
embraced particularly by
Adorno--
those last are the two
aesthetic modes that we passed
in review last time--
and finally,
as a fifth notion,
the idea that realism being
somehow outworn,
having developed hardening of
the arteries as a kind of a
bourgeois perspective on things,
needs somehow or another to be
replaced aesthetically in the
Marxist view of things by
something else.
Perhaps the most eloquent
proponent of replacing it with
something is Jameson,
who earlier in the introductory
chapter of The Political
Unconscious--
much of which you've been
assigned for today--
writes a section which he calls
"Magical Narratives"
and which promotes,
very much in keeping with the
thinking of Northrop Frye about
the role of romance in society--
and particularly the religious
role of romance in society--
proposes that an aesthetic of
the romance which entails
folklore,
the folk tale,
the fairy tale,
and various forms of folk
expression as a magical
resolution of conflicts that
can't otherwise be resolved,
is the more appropriate
aesthetic to take up.
The long passage that I sent to
you last night,
which I'd like quickly to go
over, is meant to further the
promotion of this aesthetic and
also to pose for us a critique
of what the consequences would
be of lingering with a realist
aesthetic.
So Jameson says,
on the second passage on your
sheet:
Let Scott, Balzac and Dreiser
serve as the [and remember that
Balzac is the favorite author of
Engels;
Scott is the favorite author,
at least in 1927,
of Lukacs;
and Dreiser is a figure from
the so-called naturalist
movement, the American novelist
who is a very appropriate
addition to the list.
It's in that context that
Jameson is dropping these
particular names]
non-chronological markers of
the emergence of realism in its
modern form.
These first great realisms are
characterized by a fundamental
and exhilarating heterogeneity
in their raw materials,
and by a corresponding
versatility in their narrative
apparatus.
At such moments a generic
confinement to the existent [in
other words,
the only thing you have to do
if you're a realist is talk
about things the way they really
are]
has a paradoxically liberating
effect on the registers of the
text and releases a set of
heterogeneous historical
perspectives:
the past for Scott,
the future for Balzac,
and the process of
commodification for Dreiser--
normally felt to be
inconsistent with a focus on the
historical present.
In other words,
in Scott's treatment of history
as dialectical,
against the foil of the present
there is envisioned a kind of
romanticized evocation of a
feudal past,
and so it is in turn--I don't
want to linger long over this
with the other writers.
Indeed, this multiple
temporality tends to be sealed
off and re-contained again in
high realism and naturalism [in
other words,
it starts getting too easy,
and the formulas of
representing and evoking the
real begin to become,
as I said, sclerotic.
They begin to harden.
They begin to confine us in
ways that had hitherto been
liberating]
where a perfected narrative
apparatus,
in particular the threefold
imperatives of authorial
depersonalization--
that is to say,
the voice in style indirect
libre,
authorial depersonalization;
unity of point of view,
and restriction to scenic
representation begin to confer
on the realistic option the
appearance of an asphyxiating
self-imposed penance.
In other words,
"this is all I can say and
this is the only way I can say
it.
There are no other
possibilities of literary
expression because I now feel
confined to this reification of
the real,
this insistence that the real,
the evocation of the real,
is my only literary option,
and so it's no longer
liberating."
It is in the context of this
gradual reification in late
capitalism that the romance once
again comes to be felt as the
place of narrative heterogeneity
and freedom from the reality
principle.
That is,
in a way, a jab at Freud,
but at the same time an
acknowledgement that Freud
participates in a sort of
growing despair over the
necessity of confining oneself
to the real,
evoking freedom from the
reality principle to which a now
oppressive realistic
representation is the hostage.
Okay.
So that's the aesthetic of
Fredric Jameson,
and before we begin an
analysis--that is to say,
before we begin to consider his
three horizons or concentric
circles of interpretation--
from other points of view,
I thought it would be
interesting to find this
romance aesthetic in
those three levels.
We're talking,
of course, about the
"political,"
the "social,"
and the "historical":
the political,
the kind of chronicle-like--as
he puts it--
record of successive happenings
in a fictive context,
constructed as a plot by some
individual voice;
the social as the
conflict--or emergence into our
awareness of its being a
conflict--
of what Jameson calls
"ideologemes"--
that is to say,
ways of thinking about the
world as expressed by disparate
and conflicting classes;
and then finally the
historical,
which Jameson calls
"necessity."
At the end of the essay,
he says it's "what
hurts," but in terms of
literary analysis,
as we'll see,
it has to do with understanding
the overlap of the succession of
modes of production as they
unfold in historical time.
We'll have more to say about
modes of production,
but our basic three horizons,
then--
in which I am now going to look
for the romance aesthetic--
our basic three horizons,
then, are what Jameson calls
the political,
the social and the historical.
It's important that he does
sometimes call them
concentric circles,
because you have to understand
that as you advance through the
three stages,
you're not leaving anything
behind.
The political is contained
within the social and the social
is contained within the
historical.
All of that is what is not to
be left behind but is rather to
be rethought,
reconsidered.
Jameson sometimes uses the word
"rewritten,"
thinking of the text that is
the object of one's study as one
advances through these three
stages.
So that's why he thinks it
appropriate to call them
concentric circles.
So what is the essential
political moment of the
creative act?
Well, it's what Jameson,
borrowing from Kenneth Burke,
calls "the symbolic
act."
As an individual writer,
I undertake to resolve
symbolically a contradiction--
and Marxism is always about
contradiction:
that is to say,
the way in which the
perspective of any class exists
in a contradictory relation both
with its own needs and desires
and with other classes.
In any case,
then, the symbolic act at the
political level is designed to
resolve a contradiction that
can't be resolved by other
means.
In other words,
it's a fantasy,
it is the fairy tale,
it is the princess and the
pauper.
It is the arbitrary happy
ending tacked onto a situation
for which in reality there would
be no happy ending.
In other words,
it is a romance perspective
about the world,
the realistic approach to which
would somehow or another leave
us feeling much more confined.
"Slumdog Millionaire"
is an interesting example.
It's an auteur film made by
Danny Boyle,
an interesting example of an
individual act which magically
resolves a contradiction through
the whole Bollywood apparatus
that it brings to bear on it.
The contradictions,
of course, are rife between
Hindu and Muslim,
the contradictions entailed in
globalization,
the contradictions of
caste--all of these
contradictions,
not to be resolved on a
realistic plane,
nevertheless can be resolved by
an individual symbolic act:
You hit the Lotto.
You win against all odds a
prize that makes you a
millionaire.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
Well, we all
>
want to be millionaires,
but only one of us
miraculously,
magically, through a series of
completely implausible
happenstances,
is able to do so.
Now notice this:
it's not that it doesn't
happen.
People do hit the Lotto.
People do win the $64,000
question or whatever it is.
It's not that it's absolute
never-never land,
but the point is--and I think
this is really ultimately the
point of that extravagant dance
in the railroad station at the
end of the film--
the point is that even were it
to happen in reality,
it wouldn't resolve
contradictions.
That is to say,
your life would not have that
kind of scripted perfection:
You get the girl,
everything is going to be
perfect, and the whole world
falls in line,
dancing behind you.
This just
>
doesn't happen.
In other words,
it can be sort of tragic to hit
the Lotto, as many stories of
that kind have made clear to us.
That, it seems to me,
is finally how the film is
somewhat self-conscious about
its nature as a symbolic act.
Anyway, that's the romance
element of the political level
of interpretation as understood
by Jameson.
Now the second level brings to
the surface the element of
subversion that has to be
entailed in this same fairy tale
resolution of a conflict that
can't otherwise be resolved.
There are all sorts of other
aspects at the second level,
but remember I'm discovering
the romance aesthetic here in
all three levels before turning
to other matters having to do
with them.
At the second level,
on page 1297,
the right-hand column,
you have Ernst Bloch's
understanding of the fairy tale.
This is at the second level,
about two thirds of the way
down.
Thus, for instance,
Bloch's reading of the fairy
tale,
with its magical
wish-fulfillments and its
Utopian fantasies of plenty and
the pays de Cocagne,
restores the dialogical
["The Big Rock Candy
Mountain"
basically is the pays
de Cocagne]
and antagonistic content of
this "form"
by exhibiting it as a
systematic deconstruction and
undermining of the hegemonic
aristocratic form of the
epic…
In other words,
it's not just a symbolic act,
the fairy tale.
It is a thumbing of the nose at
hegemony.
It is, in other words,
an act of antagonism which,
of course, recognizes the
impossibility of resolution or
reconciliation precisely in its
register of antagonism;
so that at the second level,
the social level,
in which the ideological voices
of various classes and
perspective are openly in
conflict,
you don't get resolution.
What you get is subversion and
reaction.
You get, in other words,
a tension of voices that is not
meant to resolve anything but is
rather meant to lay bare the
conflicts that are entailed.
Still, however,
in doing this you get the kind
of carnivalesque uprising from
below which Jameson associates
with romance:
that letting off of steam,
that entertaining of the
possibility of utopia that you
get,
for example,
in the early modern period on
that day in which someone is
called the Lord of Misrule,
the entire social order for one
day is inverted,
the low are elevated to
positions of authority,
and for one day you get the
keys to the castle,
in effect.
This is a day in which conflict
is expressed and not resolved
because everybody knows that
tomorrow it's going to be the
same old-same old and back to
business as usual;
but there is still the romance
element,
the idea that folk expression
is simultaneously the expression
of a wish,
a wish similar to the wish
that's expressed at the first
political level but the
expression of a wish which is
collective--
that is to say,
in behalf of a class and a
perspective,
and which is also,
with great self-consciousness,
not a wish that can in any way
expect to be fulfilled,
but rather one that is used
subversively with respect to the
dominant ideology that it
expresses its abrasiveness
toward.
The third level involves the
way in which there is at any
given time at the historical
level a dominant mode of
production.
A mode of production is a
system of thought or production
generated by an overarching
social or economic arrangement.
Jameson lists them in his text,
and we'll come back to them and
we'll read that listing and
we'll think about those terms;
but Jameson gives an excellent
example of the way in which,
in the latter part of the
eighteenth century,
the Enlightenment began to be
the dominant form of expression
of an emergent mercantile,
successfully capitalist
bourgeoisie.
That is to say,
the values that drove the
development of industrialization
and capital were those values
emerging from feudal and
aristocratic ideals that were
less realistic,
less engaged with actuality and
the way in which you can
actually get things done in the
world.
The Enlightenment is understood
as an expression of an emerging
new mode of production,
or capitalism as it succeeds
feudalism.
But Jameson points out--and
here's where romance comes in,
and then after that we'll move
on to our next point--
that at the same time you get
Enlightenment,
at the same time that that does
seem to become the dominant form
of expression,
you also get two modes of
resistance or contestation.
On the one hand you have
Romanticism,
which can be understood in this
context as a kind of atavistic
throwback to aristocratic and
feudal idealism,
codes of conduct,
beliefs, visions of utopia
within Romanticism--
all of them sort of trying to
recode in an age of
Enlightenment various sorts of
idealism that had come to seem
outmoded.
So that's a kind of,
as it were, reactionary mode of
production overlapping with or
expressing itself through the
dominant one.
Then at the same time,
you get folk resistance
to the increasing mechanization
of the Enlightenment.
With Political Economy,
with the rise of social
engineering and with the various
forms of social organization
associated with Utilitarianism,
you get folk resistance.
You get popular resistance in
the forms of protest,
"frame-breaking,"
disruption of labor activity,
protest against
industrialization,
all of which also--
because it insists on earlier
forms of agricultural and
industrial cottage industries
and so on--
is atavistic,
also a throwback to the way in
which labor is performed or
conducted under feudalism.
So that, too,
in the form of folk
expression--
of longing for,
in this case,
a utopian past,
more agrarian,
more individualized as a mode
of labor,
and more cottage-oriented--in
all of this you get an
overlapping mode of production.
So the tension among modes of
production,
which is the focus of analysis
at the historical level,
the third historical level,
can also be understood in terms
of the romance of utopian
nostalgia.
All right.
So that,
then, just to show how
Jameson's aesthetic,
his sense of the importance of
romance,
can be seen to pervade the way
in which he understands analysis
at all three of these levels.
So that's his aesthetic.
The question then is:
what is the
interpretative payoff of
undertaking literary analysis at
these three levels?
That is to say,
why should we take the trouble
to do it?
What's so interesting about it?
Well, from Jameson's point of
view--
this, of course,
is the title of his book--
each of these three modes of
analysis is designed to
disclose,
to uncover, to lay bare an
element of the "political
unconscious."
As for deconstruction,
as for Freud,
this sense of a political
unconscious exposes or reveals
something that is antithetical
to ordinary consciousness--
that is to say,
undermines our conventional
understanding of things,
shows us that beneath our
conventional understanding of
things there are laws and causes
and dynamics at work that we
need to understand.
In this case,
however, the unconscious in
question is not a linguistic
unconscious;
it is not a psychological
unconscious.
It is a political unconscious.
Insofar, in other words,
as we are political animals,
the acts that we perform,
the dialogues that we engage
in,
the modes of production that we
participate in--
all of them have political
ramifications;
that is to say,
we do what we do,
as opposed to doing other
things,
for political reasons of which
we may not be fully aware--
hence the emphasis in analysis
of this kind on the political
unconscious.
So again the three levels.
Going back to the idea of the
"symbolic"
act: what political
unconscious, in other words,
is revealed by a symbolic act?
Well, Jameson gives a wonderful
example taken from
structuralism,
and you can see that he leans
very heavily on structuralism
for his understanding of the way
in which something is going on
in a narrative form of which it
is not immediately apparent that
anybody can be aware.
Take for example Caduveo face
painting.
Levi-Strauss asks both in
The Savage Mind and again
in Tristes Tropiques:
why the excessive complexity
of these paintings?
Why the curious tension in the
marks on the faces between the
vertical and the horizontal?
Why, in other words,
do you get a feeling of
tension,
of aesthetic beauty but also of
tension and complication,
in this cross-hatching,
in this sense of the relation
between the vertical and the
horizontal?
So Jameson's argument,
which he brings out more
clearly than Levi-Strauss--
but Levi-Strauss does say the
same thing,
contrasting the Caduveo in this
respect with neighboring tribes
like the Bororo--
his explanation is that the
Caduveo are a hierarchical
society in which there are open
and obvious forms of inequality
that one must perforce be aware
of as a member of the tribe,
but that neighboring tribes,
(and this is something that
probably the tribe itself can
observe) work out a way of
seeming to resolve the
contradictions inherent in
hierarchy by the exchange of
moieties,
which is to say,
of kinship gifts and wedding
gifts and so on--
that Levi-Strauss talks about.
This exchange of moieties seems
to impose on these social orders
in real life,
in real terms,
a way of making society more
equal than it might otherwise
be.
Yes, it's still hierarchical,
but at the same time,
wealth is distributed,
each person has his own form of
asserting dignity,
and so on.
The Caduveo doesn't have this.
Levi-Strauss's and Jameson's
point is that the Caduveo never
really worked that out,
so they're stuck with a simple
form of hierarchical
organization.
Face painting,
then, according to Levi-Strauss
followed by Jameson,
is their way of symbolically
resolving the problem by
introducing the horizontal--
by introducing,
in other words,
the ways in which other tribes
have successfully offset
hierarchy with ways of
distributing wealth and prestige
more equally.
The symbolic act which other
tribes were able to accomplish
in real life,
in real terms,
the Caduveo accomplish
individually,
with each individual woman
painting her face as a symbolic
act,
a symbolic act expressing the
political unconscious--
because this is not an act,
we suppose,
of which any individual is
aware.
The unawareness,
the lack of consciousness of
what's going on in a story,
is much more readily available
to us in the Oedipus myth
because that's the part of
Levi-Strauss's "Structural
Study of Myth"
that we happen to have read.
The next part is
>
Caduveo face painting,
but in "The Structural
Study of Myth,"
Levi-Strauss begins by talking
about the Oedipus myth.
Well, the whole point of that
is, "Gee,
there's a terrible
contradiction,
born from two or born from
one."
Plainly, no individual version
of the story,
certainly not Sophocles'
version, is saying to itself,
"Oh, this is a terrible
contradiction.
I don't know whether I'm born
from two people or born from one
person."
That is the unconscious,
in other words,
of the story which is brought
out, brought to the surface,
by a structuralist analysis of
the myth.
Jameson doesn't talk about it
because it's not in any obvious
and immediate way a political
problem or a problem susceptible
of Marxist analysis.
It is perhaps
ultimately--everything is--
but not immediately,
and so he turns instead to a
discussion of the Caduveo myth,
which has as its unconscious an
issue that's obviously a
political one,
but it is nevertheless the case
that a structural analysis of a
symbolic act is designed to and
will inevitably reveal an
element of unconscious thought,
political or otherwise.
That then is the way in which
the political unconscious,
as Jameson describes it,
is brought out at the first
political level of
understanding,
the individual symbolic act.
Now at the second level,
the social,
in which the text,
as Jameson says,
rewrites itself not as an
individual act but as,
very much in the spirit of
Bakhtin,
a heteroglossal expression of
voices,
of points of view,
writing themselves as it were
through the text--
there the political unconscious
in question is something that
has to be understood in terms of
ideologemes.
In other words,
people reflexively express,
perhaps unbeknownst to
themselves, views and opinions
which are intelligible not
arising out of their
individuality,
not because they are who they
are, as they themselves might
say--
but rather because of their
economic class and prestige
status.
In other words,
because of their place in the
world, it follows that they will
hold certain views.
They will be the mouthpieces,
in other words,
for certain ideologemes,
and those ideologemes Jameson
understands to be at least in
part unconscious.
One doesn't know,
in other words,
that the opinions one so
fervently expresses and so
devoutly believes in are
opinions conditioned by the
social circumstances in which
one finds oneself,
so that literature then
becomes a kind of drama of
ideologemes,
a representation of unresolved
conflict that manifests in the
variety of class or status
voices brought to bear.
You can see this is the point
at which Jameson's work is
closest to Bakhtin's and most
clearly reflects some of the
preoccupations of Bakhtin as we
have encountered them already.
Jameson gives a very good
example of the way in which this
conflict works--
because part of the mystery of
these clashes is that they
always present themselves within
a shared code.
This already begins to look
forward to the idea of the mode
of production.
At the bottom of page 1296,
Jameson is talking about the
violent religious controversies
of the seventeenth century in
England between Cavalier and
Roundhead,
with all the controversies
surrounding the interregnum of
Cromwell,
the restoration of Charles the
Second,
and the tremendous ferment,
largely religious ferment,
taking place during that period;
but this ferment for any
Marxist--and Christopher Hill is
the leading historian writing
about this period who has made
it most clearly intelligible in
these terms--
for any Marxist this conflict
has an underlying political
unconscious: that is,
its ultimate motives are an
assertion of rights and an
expression of class views.
This is the way Jameson puts
it, bottom of page 1296:
"…the normal form
of the dialogical is essentially
an antagonistic
one…"
He's alluding here to Bakhtin,
for whom frequently the
dialogical is simply a kind of
happy cacophony of voices,
a carnivalesque expression of
chaos from below,
all of which is a kind of
yeast-like ferment,
and somehow or another in the
long run energizing and socially
progressive.
But Jameson points out that the
ideologeme is very often
expressive of conflict as well,
an antagonistic one,
and that the dialogue of class
struggle is one in which two
opposing discourses fight it out
within the general unity of a
shared code.
Thus, for instance,
the shared master code of
religion becomes in the 1640s in
England the place in which the
dominant formulations of a
hegemonic theology are
re-appropriated and polemically
modified.
In other words,
the Church of England stands
for--and this is the word that
was used--"esta
blishment."
Roundhead points of view,
various forms of Puritanism and
other forms of religious
rebellion,
are antiestablishment,
and yet they are all coded
within the discourse of the
Christian religion.
That is to say,
they have to fight it out on a
common battlefield,
and that's the way it is with
conflict of this kind.
Maybe a contemporary example
would be not so much in the
sphere of religion.
Well, today one could
speak again of religion,
but in the sixties and
seventies it was maybe more a
question of ethics.
Think, for example,
of the sexual revolution.
Again there is a common ground,
a sense of the centrality of
sexual conduct to human life;
but what you get in--not so
much, perhaps,
the conflict of classes as
conflict of generations in this
case--
what you get in the conflict of
generations is an inversion of
values,
not a new set of values exactly
but a simple transvaluation of
what exists.
Everything that one faction
considers bad,
another faction transvalues and
considers good.
The very thing against which
one is warned is the thing that
one rushes to embrace and so on.
So once again you get a clash,
an unresolved clash,
but a clash that arises from
and participates in the semiotic
structure of a common code,
right?
That's the way in which social
antagonism expresses itself at
the second level,
and it usually involves,
because there are underlying
interests,
elements of the political
unconscious and brings to the
surface elements of the
political unconscious.
Finally, at the third level
what comes out,
what is made manifest,
is the tension or clash among
modes of production as they
jostle each other historically.
It's understood that the
danger, as Jameson puts it,
of thinking in terms of a
succession of modes of
production is that each one of
those modes of production might
seem like a synchronic moment.
In other words,
if you're in capitalism,
you might get lulled into
thinking that no other mode of
production is available.
If you're in patriarchy,
you might get lulled into
thinking that no other mode of
production is available;
yet as Jameson points out,
the tension between corporate
hierarchy and patriarchal
hierarchy--
the tension,
in other words,
which very often drives a wedge
and has driven a wedge in
polemic between Marxist and
feminist points of view--
is a reflection of the
coexistence of modes of
production from completely
different eras:
one contemporary,
one completely--at least
insofar as it was the dominant--
a thing of the past,
and yet persisting and still
overlapping with a mode of
production that is contemporary.
All of that is simply a matter
of historical fact,
but in literary analysis you
begin to think of it in more
formal terms,
and you see,
for example,
the very choice of verse form--
and I'm taking as an example
Shelley's famous poem "The
Ode to the West Wind"--
you see the very choice of
verse form as an instance of
what Jameson calls "the
ideology of form"
that can be understood in terms
of the conflict of modes of
production.
The verse form of Shelley's
"Ode to the West Wind"
has five strophes,
and each strophe is exactly the
same in form.
It is simultaneously a sonnet
and--the first twelve lines of
which, concluding in a
couplet--a succession of terza
rima.
Now these two forms brought
together, synthesized as a
single strophic form in Shelley,
are coded in entirely different
ways.
Each aspect of them has an
ideology.
Terza rima is coded
"prophecy"
because it is in the tradition
of Dante.
It's the verse form in which
The Divine Comedy is
written,
and it is a mode that is
expressive of hope that resolves
all contradiction in the divine,
in the revelation of the
divine, in The
Paradiso; so that
terza rima expresses for Shelley
the hope of the poem,
which is that the west wind
will be through him the trumpet
of a political prophecy.
If winter's here,
can spring be far behind?
Revolution is in the offing,
everything's going to be great.
But at the same time,
the poem is shot through with a
kind of pessimism--a sort of,
if you will,
realism;
an awareness that this notion
of prophecy is rather
farfetched.
Why should the wind do his
bidding?
The wind is just wind.
It's not inspiration.
Therefore, the very stanza
which is written in terza rima
is written at the same time as a
sonnet, fourteen lines.
The first stanza in particular
is coded not just as a sonnet
but also as an allusion
specifically to one sonnet,
Shakespeare's seventy-third
sonnet,
which begins "That time of
year in me thou mayest
behold"--
in which I'm getting old.
I don't have any hair left.
I'm just a bare-ruined choir
where late sweet birds sang.
In other words,
I am in a parlous state,
I am getting old,
and there's nothing to be done
about it.
At the end of the poem,
the embers of my fire are about
to be snuffed out.
There is just no hope for it.
That's the way it is:
you get old.
In other words,
winter's here and spring isn't
coming.
There is no prophetic
possibility.
There is only the reality of
the trajectory of a life spent.
If there is rise,
there is also fall.
If there is development,
there is also decline and
decay,
and these, as the sonnet form
codes it,
are simple facts of life that
poetic idealism,
that Romanticism,
cannot override.
So what you get in Shelley's
verse form is a tension between
ideas,
the prophetic idea which you
can associate with a feudal and
theocentric world in which the
contradictions of reality really
can be resolved theologically,
on the one hand,
and a kind of proto-realist
tradition in which we just have
to come to terms with the way
things are,
coded through--which is,
after all,
proto-Enlightenment,
and Shakespeare is often sort
of thought of as a
proto-Enlightenment figure-- the
sonnet.
So formally,
both the terza rima and the
sonnet participate in what
Jameson calls "the ideology
of form,"
and they reflect modes of
production,
feudal and Enlightenment
respectively.
They reflect attitudes that one
can associate with those modes
of production.
So that's an example of the way
in which the political--
perhaps one had better call it
quasi-conscious because Shelley
was an incredibly self-conscious
poet--
the way in which the political
"quasi-conscious"
expresses itself at the third
or historical level of analysis.
Now in formal terms--and I have
already sort of gotten into
this,
and I'll go through it rather
quickly because there isn't much
time left--
in formal terms we can think of
the essential critical task at
the first or political level as
one of thematization.
That is to say,
what theme is the plot
structure of an individual
symbolic act trying to express?
What is the contradiction
that's being resolved in this
symbolic act?
At the second level,
the formal principle that we do
bring to bear is the idea,
the Bakhtinian idea,
of heteroglossia:
the clash of voices,
the way in which the voice is
no longer individual but rather
social,
the representative of a social
point of view that expresses
itself through the individual
author's writing.
At the third level,
you get what Jameson calls
"a repertoire of
devices,"
and I have already reflected a
little bit on that.
Let me just add another
example, also taken from
Romanticism,
in keeping with Jameson's
exemplification of the overlap
of modes of production as being
particularly interesting in the
age of Enlightenment.
In Romanticism there is a long
tradition leading up to it of
the formal Pindaric ode.
Wordsworth is still making use
of that tradition in writing his
ode,
"Intimations of
Immortality,"
but in the meantime he and
Coleridge have developed a new
kind of ode,
if you will,
which is called the
"conversation poem":
Coleridge's "Frost at
Midnight"
and "This Lime-Tree Bower
My Prison,"
Wordsworth's "Tintern
Abbey" are notable examples
of the conversation poem.
Now the difference is very
clearly intelligible in terms of
a conflict of modes of
production.
The formal ode,
derived ultimately from Pindar
celebrating Olympic victories of
aristocratic patrons in Greece--
horse races,
foot races, wrestling matches:
that's the original purpose to
which the formal ode was put--
plainly is coded once again as
feudal-aristocratic,
whereas the conversation poem
belongs very much,
as the word suggests,
in the public sphere.
It's the atmosphere of the
coffeehouse.
It's the atmosphere in which
people sit down and talk
together, exchange views,
and address each other.
It is a poem always of address
to some individual person that
turns to that person at a
certain point,
evokes the nature of that
person, sometimes solicits that
person's opinions.
In other words,
it's a poem that performs
dialogism.
It's a poem that performs the
sense of the give-and-take of a
much more open,
democratic culture in the
public sphere.
So you can see that the very
transition from the formal ode
to the conversation poem is
itself intelligible as a
transition between--
or what Jameson calls "a
cultural revolution"
brought in by a seismic shift
in--
modes of production.
All right.
So these exemplify,
in various ways,
what can be done with these
three levels.
Jameson himself reminds us of
the dangers.
If we think of a narrative as a
symbolic act,
we are much too prone either to
forget that it's based on
reality by emphasizing the
structuralist nature of what's
going on or to forget that form
is involved at all by
emphasizing the social
contradiction that's being
resolved.
As Jameson says,
these two dangers at the first
level are the danger of
structuralism and the danger of
vulgar materialism.
The point in analyzing the
symbolic act is to sustain a
balance or a synthesis between
formal and social elements
within the text.
At the second level,
the problem is that if we start
thinking in terms of
un-reconcilable class conflict,
our analysis can become static,
as though class perspectives
didn't shift,
as though one perspective might
not succeed another as the
hegemonic: in other words,
as though change didn't take
place,
as though there was always the
same old-same old in class
conflict.
The boss is always going to
speak demeaningly of the worker.
The worker is always going to
laugh at the boss behind his
back.
This is the way it is;
this is the way it will always
be.
There are static relations in
other words among the classes
that history can't resolve.
Finally, at the third level,
there is the danger of thinking
in terms of impasse--
late capitalism,
for example,
as an impasse that simply can't
be surmounted.
Think of Adorno and his
incredible gloom about the
culture industry.
There isn't much hope in
Adorno, >
is there?
And by the same token,
you could argue that poor old
Jameson talking about history as
necessity,
history as what hurts,
history as just what has
happened--
by the same token,
you could argue that Jameson,
too, is perhaps a little bit
subject to this sense of
impasse,
which is why I quote for you,
as these people themselves
often do,
the ringing warning of Marx in
the Eleventh Thesis on
Feuerbach: "The
philosophers have only
interpreted the world in various
ways.
The point, however,
is to change it."
That is ultimately the focus of
Marx's analysis.
Let's revisit Tony in
the remaining minute.
Now a reified realist approach
to Tony,
the kind that Jameson
criticizes on the sheet,
would point out that nothing
happens to Neato and Speedy.
They are manifest villains,
and yet at the same time,
nothing can happen to them.
They simply have their place in
the social order:
one of them is a fastidious
aristocrat who doesn't want to
get dirty,
the other is completely
committed to productivity and
the time clock and the work
ethic,
a bourgeois Speedy.
There they are;
nothing to be done.
They're not nice to Tony but
nothing happens to them.
There is no recrimination.
But then at the first level,
if we understand this as a
symbolic act,
the resolution of what would
otherwise be a hopeless conflict
is through friendship--
the friendship of Bumpy and
Tony;
the fact that it's perfectly
okay if I'm just a working guy.
I've got my buddies.
We go out.
We drink beer.
We have a good time.
Life is great.
It doesn't matter,
in other words,
that there's a class structure,
that there's a social system.
"I'm happy,"
Tony says in effect.
"I like my job."
That in itself,
of course, is a resolution,
>
is a symbolic act and a
resolution in advance of the
conflicts that the story might
otherwise manifest.
At the second level,
you get the discourse of
ideologemes.
"I can't help you,"
says Neato the car.
"I don't want to get
dirty."
"I can't help you,"
says Speedy the car.
"I am too busy."
"I can help you,"
says Bumpy;
but notice that this is all
within an individual,
single code,
and that's what the complete
parallelism of these three
utterances shows us.
Within a single code,
these ideologemes,
which can't really be resolved,
get themselves expressed.
All right.
Now finally modes of
production: plainly,
the very existence of Neato and
Speedy in the same story
suggests that there is a certain
tension between the feudal and
the bourgeois at work,
but it's not a tension that in
any way necessarily works itself
out.
The important thing to notice
here, it seems to me,
is the conflict between pulling
and pushing.
It's very interesting--and I've
said this before--that a tow
truck, something that pulls--and
once again Tony is a mode of
production, right?
He's a tow truck, right?
And something that pulls has to
be pushed.
Bumpy, like the Little Engine
that Could, is a sort of a
throwback to an earlier,
less energized,
less powerful mode of
production.
He has to push.
Think of the way walls get put
up: a prefabricated wall before
the invention of the crane and
the pulley has to be pushed up
by a bunch of people.
Pushing is the essential labor
mode before the kind of
technology arises that makes it
possible to pull something.
After that, you have a crane.
You run the hook down,
and you just pull the wall up
into place.
Before then,
you got maybe one person
standing on a rafter with a rope
kind of pulling but everybody
else is down on the ground
pushing;
and so the relationship between
pushing and pulling in the story
is a crucially important one
which suggests the overlap of
older and newer modes of
production,
all of which can be resolved at
Jameson's third or historical
level of analysis.
Okay.
So much then for Jameson and
for Tony.
We'll be coming back to Tony
again next time in the
context of talking about the New
Historicism.